do you feel like after saturday night
fever
did you see it did you go oh wow this is
oh yeah this is it that was the
blueprint i'm going to be
a major star like i'm i'm i'm here like
now now that i feel i've gotta i've got
an opportunity to really put my talent
on display
i'm going to be
the next biggest movie star of this town
we'll see i did for this reason
the second
indication if you will
of
having a solidity in the movie industry
was a director called terence malik and
he directed um very important films in
the 70s and he wanted me called for a
film called days of heaven
and i screen tested for it right before
right after carrie and before boiling
the plastic bubble
and i got the i got the roll
and i
couldn't do it because
wolper and eiser wouldn't let me out of
cotter
but it was such a significant role and
that richard gere ended up doing which
ended up a theme where he did many roles
i didn't do
but
that was another
last detail opportunity like the
nicholson the second time so between the
last detail and uh days of heaven i
really got the idea that
the force wanted me
to be a film
so by the time i got the saturday night
fever opportunity i said i'm gonna make
this work i'm gonna do everything i can
to make this
a authentic
great performance well i mean it's
that's kind of insane though for you to
for you to see the trajectory of those
that ended up taking the parts that you
didn't get
and what that
then went on and meant for those you
know for those actors oh yeah so no i
take responsibility for richard and tom
hanks is enough for everybody you know
there's it's arts aren't you know
shouldn't be hoarded
you know there's there's a i mean
i
i was the the role in
the hank's film called splash was
written for me the mermaid mermaid yeah
yeah yeah yeah so uh you know but then
we wouldn't have tom hanks so let's have
tom hanks do you see what i mean so what
what what is the relationship
of of the actors at that time like you
know you're mentioning these these
massive names which all at the same time
are young young ambitious
driven and all looking for their
opportunities and you guys naturally
you're you're bumping heads constantly
because you're always up for the same
things that are supposed to be the
biggest thing and this is the irony of
it or interesting part of it i should
say
there was very few of us and up
now
there's a ton of people competing it's
much more difficult to establish
yourself in any aspect music
movies it's easier and it's more
difficult you know depending on how your
avenue is but
it was just
richard gere myself tree williams
up for most parts so if
i didn't get it one of those guys would
young where was tom at that time and
then tom was a few years later yeah yeah
so maybe like it by 81 or two tom came
into the scene so then it was tom so it
was richard
tree myself and tom
and
those roles would get
interchangeable do you see
depending on
what was happening
and it
so in some ways
i mean in vegas what's a one out of four
chance you know what i mean it was it
was a good
your odds aren't bad yes
you're playing with good odds based on
the talent that's known to be the major
talent in town at that time i totally
understand and we were a new generation
because a generation right before me
was the stallone de niro
uh pacino generation and then i was the
beginning of that next generation which
included myself
and tom hanks and richard and and uh
treat and that group where's denzel at
this time uh he came a few years later
as
mel gibson
was around the mid 80s or early 80s so
denzel and and uh denzel's we're the
same age
and mel we're uh we're a little later
that's insane i i love this is this is
why i love this yeah the the
it's so interesting when you really dive
into
you know the mind of the person that was
operating back then yeah and if i were
you i'd be asking the same question if i
had the luxury in my day
of interviewing uh cagney or you know
someone else i would be asking these
very same questions because i love the
chronology of of a life
and of a career and to find out what was
real to that person and what wasn't it
it's really i i'm very impressed that
you even want to ask these questions if
you don't take advantage of your
opportunity to be a sponge and soak up
information i i think you're wasting
you're wasting the time of these
valuable relationships and that's why
you're so successful because you get
that thank you i think it's very
important
you